[Music]
pilgrims come from all over the world to
get that in the Holy Land in the old
stems some of those stamps are older
than the United States they were passed
down in my family from one generation to
another I was in Razoo and I am the 27th
generation of the oldest deterring
family in the world this great big story
is inspired by Genesis
the cross tattoo on the wrist is the
ultimate proof of pilgrimage to the Holy
Land they are now reborn Christians they
are proud of the journey that they have
done when they understand the history
and our lineage they want to be tattooed
by us I learned tutoring from my father
who learnt it from his father my son is
the 28th generation my family we're
doing tattoos in Egypt just like mine
here a small little cross on the wrist
when they came to the Holy Land five
hundred years ago they discovered a
tradition where Christians would get a
tattoo as a mark of the pilgrimage so my
family decided to stay here and continue
this tradition your stamp is 500 years
old
guaranteed all right okay among the
tools that we have in the family that
has been passed down our beautiful old
wooden stamps that are hundreds of years
old and those stamps are very simple
just outlined designs but very intricate
and very charming and that's why a lot
of people like them we get people from
all over the world who come to get a
tattoo out of old wooden stamp that has
touched so many pilgrims who have done
the same journey that they are doing so
they are becoming part of this history
part of this tradition and part of this
heritage what we are doing here is not a
cosmetic tattoo it's a tattoo that has
way more deeper meaning
and the superficial skin you're actually
reflecting what they have felt when they
came to the Holland and now they want to
reflect that on their skin it's almost
like baptism is almost like baptizing
somebody and that's a big responsibility
at the same time it's greatly satisfying
to feel that you are that special person
that they want you to tattoo them it's
for the tradition it's for that special
thing in their life that has happened to
them that they want to be marked by
you
[Music]